hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar highly multiplexed
single-cell westerns for exploring
heterogeneity and protein kinase C
signaling and CRISPR knockdown
efficiency I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
roots and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provide our virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by proteins
simple proteins simple is part of the
analytical solutions division of biotech
knee proteins simple is rethinking
protein tools and helping thousands of
researchers around the world resolve
their protein analysis problems so they
can reveal new insight into proteins and
their role in disease the company's
wide-ranging portfolio of tools includes
everything from immunoassay systems that
quantify protein expression to systems
that probe the structure and purity of
protein based therapeutics to learn more
visit www.kingston.com/support for
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top-right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present today's speakers nimi today MD
staff scientist for the collaborative
protein technology resource in the
office of science and technology
resource at the Center for cancer
research at the National Institutes of
Health and Kelli Gardner PhD the
director of marketing for Milo egg
proteins simple dr. Kadel received her
MD from the University of Debrecen in
Hungary and did research for several
years at the Department of Biochemistry
focusing on the role of tissue
transglutaminase in apoptosis
she joined the laboratory of molecular
mechanisms of tumor promotion at the
National Cancer Institute in 1999 first
as a postdoctoral fellow and later a
staff scientist about a year ago dr.
today joined the collaborative protein
technology resource where she leads the
efforts of the laboratory to implement
novel technologies for protein detection
at the single cell level including
single cell Western and multiplex
immunostaining
using codex dr. Gardner was formerly the
CEO and co-founder of Zephyrus
Biosciences the life science startup
company that originally developed the
single cell Western product line for her
work leading the company from
incorporation through to its acquisition
by proteins simple she was named one of
the top 35 entrepreneurs under 35
globally by the MIT tech review dr.
Gardner holds a PhD in bioengineering
and MBA equivalent and a Bachelors of
Science in biomedical engineering and
mechanical engineering the speakers
complete bios are found on the lab
routes website
dr. kadai and dr. gardener will now
begin their presentations
great thank you so much welcome to
today's webinar presentation my name is
Kelli Gardner director of marketing for
the Milo single cell Western platform at
protein simple and I'm really pleased to
introduce dr. Noemi kadai from the
Center for cancer research at the
National Cancer Institute at the NIH who
will share some of her work developing
highly multiplexed single cell westerns
for exploring heterogeneity in protein
kinase C signaling and CRISPR knockdown
efficiency our learning objectives today
are first to learn how single-cell
westerns work
and how signal for westerns help you
undercover new insights into your
samples then dr. kadai will present data
from two active projects at the National
Cancer Institute in her presentation you
will learn how her group is using highly
multiplexed single-cell westerns to
study header - the heterogeneity and
signaling pathways to identify cell
subpopulations with distinct activation
state you'll also learn how her group is
using single cell westerns to measure
CRISPR cast nine knockdown efficiency to
facilitate clonal selection of drop-down
cells so if you're not familiar with
single cell westerns we wanted to start
with a brief introduction to the
technology milo is the world's only
single cell Western system it brings the
power and ubiquity of Western blotting -
single cell analysis it provides Western
based protein measurements plus
heterogeneity information about your
sample to give you an idea of what the
platform can do Milo can analyze about a
thousand single cells per chip it can
multiplex to measure multiple proteins
per single cell typically people are
doing about four proteins per cell per
probing cycle but Milo can do 12 plus
proteins per cell when including
stripping and reproving the chips milo
offers time savings compared to
conventional Western blotting the total
workflow is about four to six hours with
three to four hours of that time being
hands-free and finally milo uses
conventional Western antibodies so you
don't need specialized reagents to
measure your protein targets of interest
in fact being able to use the huge
commercial catalog of Western antibodies
makes it possible to really expand
extent of the proteome that can be
measured at the single cell level and it
provides the flexibility required to
measure diverse proteins at the single
cell level including post translational
modifications like phosphorylated
proteins transcription factors and even
methylated histones involved in
signaling pathways as dr. today we'll
discuss in her work the single cell
Western system itself is composed of the
myelin instrument which is a benchtop
instrument where the single cell Western
assays
run a fluorescence microwave scanner
which is used to image the chips SC west
consumable kits which contain SC West
chips and all the buffers you need to
run your assay the full single-cell
Western assay is run within an SC West
chip which is based on cutting-edge
microfluidic technology Scout software
automates the image processing and data
analysis and as I mentioned Milo is an
open platform and so off-the-shelf
antibodies can be used for probing
biotech nee is one of the world's
largest antibodies providers and we
provide high quality antibodies from two
of our sister brands our nd systems and
Novus you can also continue to use your
favorite antibodies you're already using
in your lab and our organization also
offers world-class support to all of our
customers so how does the single celled
Western assay work the SC West chip is a
1 by 3 inch glass microscope slide with
a very thin poly acrylamide gel layer on
the surface and 6400 micro Wells pattern
into that gel you can kind of see them
in in the picture there they look like
lines but they're actually individual
micro wells so we take a cell suspension
and pipette it on top of SC West chip
and Milo can run any non-fixed
sample that you can get into single cell
suspension so this includes suspension
cells of course but also trypsin eyes
adherent cells or dissociated tissues
from there the cells are settled by
gravity into the micro Wells and we use
a Poisson distribution to capture about
a thousand single cells in the chip and
use cell concentration and the settling
time to tune the chip occupancy then we
lyse the cells in the array and we do an
SDS page separation on each single cell
lysate we then use UV light activate a
chemistry incorporated into the poly
acrylamide gel which immobilizes the
proteins into the gel and this really
eliminates the traditional transfer step
of traditional westerns then you can
probe with conventional Western
antibodies by diffusing them into the
gel we typically use an unlabeled
primary antibody and a fluorescent
secondary
and then image the chip fluorescence
milah runs a thousand single cell
westerns in parallel so here you can see
about 1/16 of an FC West chip on the
Left which contains 400 micro Wells and
you can see here an array of single cell
separations if you look at the zoomed in
image on the top right you can see six
electro phoretic lanes where the micro
wells are located at the top of each
lane and then electrophoresis is
happening downward in this view there
were single cells captured and analyzed
in four of the six lanes so each of
these four lanes contains a single cell
lysate and this particular chip has been
probed for three different protein
targets using two different spectral
channels the fluorescence plot at the
bottom is generated by scout the image
analysis software which identifies the
three protein Peaks at varying migration
distances which are proportional to each
proteins molecular weight scout software
can quantify area under the curve for
each detected protein peak which gives
you quantitative information about
protein abundance for each probe target
in each single cell Scouts a very
powerful tool and it really helps you to
automate your image analysis so how it
works is basically it finds all 6,400
lanes on each SC west chip first then he
automatically detects the peaks in each
lane Scout can help with molecular
weight sizing by tracking migration
distance of your proteins of interest
within each electronic separation and
then he can also give you area under the
curve calculations to quantify target
abundance for each target in each single
cell Scout also offers numerous data
visualization tools to display your data
the single cell Western workflow is fast
and easy to do so you can get results
within a day first you load your cells
into the SC West chip then you put the
chip into Milo Milo laces the cells in
the array does the SDS page separations
and UV immobilization step and all of
that takes about five minutes to run
then you take your chip out and probe it
on the bench
with the antibody probing chamber
provided with Milo then read your trip
out on any open format microwave scanner
most people already have access to one
of these and there's a list of
compatible scanners on our website we
can also package Milo with two scanner
options that are capable of scanning two
or three color experiments but no matter
what scanner you use the output of the
microwave scanner is a series of images
of the chip Scout reads these images in
does the automated data analysis and
helps you visualize your data the full
workflow can be done in a single day and
typically takes about four to six hours
to run Milo can measure two different
types of heterogeneity first he can
quantitate the heterogeneity and the
target expression in each of the cells
in your sample so for example he can
tell if there are some cells that have
low amounts of protein and some that
have high and this is measured by
looking at the variation in the peak
area of your target of interest across
the cells in your sample and then Milo
can also enumerate to quantify a
heterogeneity in the number of cells
present that our target positive for a
particular target so this is useful if
you for example if you want to look at
and identify subpopulations of cells in
a mixed sample by tracking phenotypic
markers there are lots of different ways
to visualize your data so for example
when quantifying heterogeneity and
target expression you might want to
create scatter plots at the peak area
across multiple samples or tip replicas
like shown in the top left and you can
also create histograms of the peak area
to see distributions of expression and
when enumerated you can also create 2d
scatter plots and then set thresholds to
determine how many cells express a
certain target for target combination
and then these can be translated into
bar charts which again quantify the
percentage of cells that are classified
as different subtypes based on the
measured protein expression levels the
SD west chips can also be archived when
Milo immobilizes a sample into the gel
after electro phoretic separation this
process is very high efficiency and
quite stable as a result the SD West
tips can be archived for up to nine
months after running your sample on
Mylo this allows researchers to
introduce time delays into their
experiment or come back later and reap
robe their samples to ask new questions
using the same sample getting the most
data out of your samples can be
particularly important for researchers
working with precious primary samples
Milo can all sign will also multiplex on
a per cell basis to detect multiple
proteins in each single cell so here you
can see some example data demonstrating
a four-plex experiment so here we're
showing data from a single cell imaged
in three different colors so the same
cell that you're seeing was captured in
the well at the top and we're just
showing images in different spectral
channels of the same lane so you can
multiplex with milo with three primary
strategies first you can spectrally
multiplex to do this you can probe your
sample with a cocktail of primary
antibodies raised in different host
species then just probe with different
spectral etags secondary antibodies and
image your chip in multiple spectral
channels so in this data we use a mouse
goat and rabbit primary antibodies and
then use donkey anti mouse donkey anti
goat and donkey anti rabbit secondary
antibodies labeled with red green and
blue dyes to detect three different
proteins in this single cell the second
strategy is to use differences in the
molecular weight of your proteins of
interest to resolve them in the same
spectral channel so here in the blue
channel you can see we probed with two
different rabbit primary antibodies and
the same fluorescently tagged secondary
so the proteins l85 8r and beta tubulin
are sufficiently different in molecular
weight that we can clearly resolve them
in electro phoretic separation and then
thirdly you can strip INRI probe the
chips so once the sample is covalently
bound into the gel it is robust to
numerous stripping and reproving cycles
up to nine cycles have been shown in the
literature with about a 50% loss in
sample after the ninth cycle as dr.
today will detail in her presentation
her group has demonstrated a powerful 11
plex assay which is one of the highest
multiplexing levels demonstrated on the
milo platform to date and so with that
I'll pause there and introduce dr. Naomi
kadai from the
National Cancer Institute at the
National Institutes of Health and let
her present her work using highly
multiplex single-cell westerns to
explore heterogeneity in protein kinase
C signaling and CRISPR knockdown
efficiency Thank You Callie and thank
you for everybody to give me the
opportunity to present our work in the
experimental section of this
presentation I would like to talk about
two project the first detection of
signal transduction events downstream of
protein kinase II at baseline and after
activation and the second is detection
of knockdown of knocks one knock down
efficiency in CRISPR cuz my manipulated
LS 513 colon cells some of the questions
we wanted to address in the first
project was how many signals can be
detected
on a single chip what is the stripping
efficiency and how many times can the
chips be stripped without significant
loss of signal what are the best loading
controls to use what is the
reproducibility of signal detection
detection in different cycles and are
there any novel findings revealed by
single cell destined in our experiments
we have used a vectorized robust system
the Lancaster's treated with PMA or DM
SOS control Allen kept prostate cancer
cells are responsive to the activation
inhibition state of protein kinase C
purple myristate acetate or DMA
activates multiple proteins by binding
to they are c1 domains and inducing
conformational change and translocation
in alien capsules there are multiple P
cases that are activated by after PMA
treatment and those include PK C alpha
delta epsilon or PK d 1 and out of each
PK c data is expressed as highest level
and is the most important for signaling
multiple changes occurred downstream of
pkc activation including
phosphorylations transcriptional changes
new protein synthesis protein
degradation some of them are weak some
of them are stronger on the diagram here
you can see the kinetics of these
changes okay and mcfist populations are
early and transient phosphorylation of
PK c data and PK d1 are more sustained
the early induced proteins eg r1 and
cephas ad can be detected after 40
minutes of PMA treatment PK c alpha gets
down regulated after a few hours by PK c
data levels don't change in these
experiments ln capsules were treated
with maximal dose maximally affected
those of PMA for 60 minutes in order for
us to be able to detect both the
phosphorylation events and the new
protein synthesis by this time
phosphorylation of Earth and Mac it's
too weak too deep to be detected
so now that you have learned or you got
some sense about what proteins we detect
in single cell less than let's get to
the data
successfully detect 11 targets using the
illustrated staining detection and
flipping cycles we detected different
ptc isoforms pkc FN p kc data we
detected phosphorylated forms of ptc
data and p KD 1 we detected newly
synthesized protein c fast EGR 1 we
detected several loading controls as
Gabby aged beta 2 villain VIN : or total
arc in our experiments we detected ptc
data in two different cycles cycle 9 and
cycle 12 is the same antibody and we
detected Cephas twice in cycle 1 and
cycle 10 using two different antibodies
we use antibodies mostly from Mouse
rabbit Mouse and rabbit and use dripping
total of seven times between application
of antibodies from the same species a
default dilution for an unknown antibody
is 1 to 10 but some of the high affinity
good antibodies can be diluted 120-180
as seen here for PK c data on the next
slide you can see two lane plots that
were generated by Scout that show the
separation of older proteins that were
loaded on the PMA chip on the x-axis you
can see the lane or the van number value
on the y-axis you can see the peak
Center for each detected signal larger
the traveling distance the smaller the
protein is so for example you can see
that 2 billion all ugh that are lower
molecular weight proteins are on the top
and winged clean with a molecular weight
of about 120 kilo daltons or PKD one run
much closer to the loading of the cell
these small tables on the right indicate
how many cells on the chip contained the
signal this ship was loaded with about
1400 cells
you
let's now see how the signal looks on
the chip through a few examples here on
the left you can see the Cephas the
inverted image of the c-4 signal from
about 1/8 of the chip and on the right
you can see how the signal really looks
basically having a darker background and
lighter spots you can also see that
Cephas was detected as two bands a
higher molecular and a lower molecular
weight a band and some cells contained
the high molecular weight form others
the low molecular weight forms or others
both Cephas is known to run as a double
band on traditional Western with an
approximate molecular weight of 50 to 58
kilo daltons
Cephas can be detected in our samples
only after PMA activation but not in
control based on how other known
proteins ran on single cell Western for
example vin Killeen or Earth we
calculated that the approximate
molecular weight of the higher molecular
weight Cephas band it's about 130 kilo
daltons why while the molecular weight
of the lower band is about 60 kilo
dalton suggesting that the two bands
detected by single cell Western as c4
that runs as monomer and dimer Cephas is
a member of the AP once transcription
factor family known to dimerize it c-jun
and other members of the family
EGR one the other newly synthesized
protein runs as a single protein on both
single service than here on the top or
on traditional Western blood shown in
the bottom the third signal that was
detected on these chips without any
stripping was a gap th and the right you
can see a very strong signal for the gap
the edge that was detected at about a
100 kilo Dalton which is four times
higher than what is expected the the
molecular weight of the gap pH is about
36 kilo daltons this behavior of grab
the edge was described earlier in a
single service term papers from kanga
toll stating that the exceedingly low
mobility of garbage in the 4 degree
Celsius conditions may be attributable
to non fully dissociated and non fully
denatured native tettemer forms up cap
th yet i would like to mention that cell
lysis and running conditions are
different for the traditional western
and a single cell Western because in
single cell Western decide the cell
lysis it's in running buffer that does
not contain any reducing agents it's
done for a very short period of time
namely 10 seconds at room temperature so
it's very possible that some of protein
complexes might not be fully dissociated
and some of the Buried epitopes might
not be fully exposed
this slide shows the for the first time
quantitative data from from our
experiments it is a modified 1d plot
showing all the signals that were
detected in the control or DMA loaded
chips it's a complicated slide so let me
just lead you through it on the x-axis
you can see all the detected signals
namely arc gap D age
Vicki C Alpha Delta tubulin just to name
a few that based on their behaviors are
grouped into non responders or
responders and the y-axis you can see
the level of the signal namely the peak
area on a logarithmic scale zero values
at a fit artificially jittered around
zero to be able to plot on a logarithmic
scale the control sample is shown in red
and the p.m. a treated sample is shown
in blue the green lines represent the
mean values while the height of the
Diamonds on the right represent
confidence intervals over all the data
from single serviced and correlates well
with the data from bulk samples detected
by traditional Western blot we can see
similar the expression of non responders
signals in control and p.m. a treated
sample you can see that on the left for
the non responders the red and blue
signals are very similar to each other
we can clearly observe target
upregulation for modulated targets in
p.m. a sample you can see higher level
of expression for cephas forceful PKD
one post facility 299 or eg odd one in a
small subpopulation of control cells we
detect some expression we detect some
expression of modulated targets but at
lower level than in the PM a treated
sample this data was further analyzed by
Josh Maho from
protein simple the database
and the PCA analysis identified as a
population of control cells that were
partially stimulated as shown by
increased phosphorylation of pkc data
and PKD one in the middle part of the
slide you can see the basal levels as
shown in red and partially activated
cells shown in purple about 30 percent
of the cells 1:100 about 100 cells were
partially activated we no such
difference were seen in stimulated cells
cells seem to all be in a similar state
after stimulation which is not a
surprise because these cells were
treated rid of fully affected those of
PMA
when the BCA analysis of both control
and PMA simulated samples were first
combined it became obvious that the
partially activated cell shown in purple
are more similar to controls as shown in
red then to PME simulated cells shown in
blue if the two samples hadn't been run
on separate chips we might not have been
able to identify the small population of
slightly simulated cells as they overlap
left with the control cells in the
combined analysis further experiments
are needed to evaluate the biologically
important of the importance of this
finding
the next slide shows two other
visualization tools provided by Scout to
present quantitative data and right now
we are going back to the c4 signal where
the Cephas was detected in two forms
under excesses you can see says that are
expressing only the high molecular
weight format cephas under viruses you
can see a cells expressing the low
molecular weight asifa's while on the
right hand side top right hand side you
can see cells expressing both the
enumeration table on the right shows
about the number of the cells and the
percentage of the cells that express
both or one or the other forms about
forty percent of the cells expressed
both the high molecular and low
molecular weight form while about twelve
percent and forty percent of cells
express only the high molecular weight
or the low molecular weight form here on
the left hand side on the of the 2d
graph you can see double negatives and
if we recalculate the numbers by
removing those double negatives and then
we find that about sixty percent of the
cells expressed both as isoforms and
eighty versus twenty percent of the
cells expressed the low molecular weight
or the high molecular weight of form
having the quantitative data we wanted
to do some comparisons between or some
correlations before different downstream
signaling events after pickasee
activation firstly compared to
phosphorylation signals you can see
phosphorylation of PK c data on the
x-axis and phosphorylation of PK d 1 on
the y axis and you can see on these two
d plots that the two signals correlate
very well next we compared the
phosphorylation of PK c data with the
synthesis of a new protein namely EGR
one
and Fausto Puglisi data is presented on
the x-axis why the EGR one is expressed
on the y-axis and again you can see that
the two signals nicely correlate
in the next step we can be correlated
the different loading controls involved
in all four graphs you can see are
presented on the x-axis and get the age
or V including presented on the y-axis
both for control and PMA samples if you
look at the graph you can see that again
the earth correlates very well with gap
the age and vehicle in both in control
and p.m. a sample we don't see so not
nice correlation between arc again
presented on the x-axis and to bullying
on the y-axis especially for PMA treated
sample most probably because tubulin is
affected by PMA treatment
one of the strongest non-responders
signal detected with the same antibody
in two different staining cycles these
graphs show p QC data staining in cycle
9 on the x-axis and B key see data
staining in cycle 12 on the y-axis and
you can see how tightly and nicely the
two signals correlate
the final comparison as part of the
essay validation was to compare the
signal the Seaforth signal detected with
two antibodies in two different signals
we compared the high molecular weight
and the low molecular weight the c-4
signal separately staining with mouse
antibody in cycle 1 is on the x-axis
staining with rabbit antibody in cycle
10 is on the y-axis and again you can
see the correlation between two the two
signals with every methodology that
includes cyclic staining and signal
removing stripping one might be
concerned about the stripping efficiency
and if any of the remaining signal
interferes with order 5 the detection of
the next signal in all our experiments
we have used harsh stripping conditions
that meant that we were incubating the
chips for 90 minutes at 30 at 65 degrees
Celsius in harsh buffer that contains 2%
SDS and mercaptoethanol we had very good
experience both with stripping
efficiency and for not having
significant effect on the proteins
remaining on the chip in our hands it
seems that the stripping efficiency is
somewhat signal dependent you can see
from the images that we could almost
fully remove Cephas and EGR 1 with
stripping but we could detect some of
the remaining a BH signal the bottom
image slipping efficiency can be
quantitated by scout on the left hand
side 1d plots you can see the level of
each signal when we compared the before
stripping and after stripping plots the
arrows the red and teal arrow shows the
change in the mean and the median of the
signal
the table shows the output from the
Scout calculations that is better
visualized probably under bar graphs at
the bottom
our conclusion was that that the
sweeping efficiency in these chips was
pretty good but additionally we also
tried to avoid detecting the same
molecular weight protein in consecutive
cycles as much as possible now we switch
to the second project the detection of
knocks one knock down efficiency in
CRISPR cos 9 manipulated LS 5:13 colon
cancer cell line and let me just start
with some introduction LS 5:13 colon
cancer cells have higher NOx one
expression than the other cancer colon
cell line used in the laboratory the HD
29 says both cell lines are used as
model systems to study the role of NOx 1
in carcinogenesis NOx one is NADPH
oxidase 1 has an important role in the
homeostasis of reactive oxygen species
and it's implicated in carcinogenesis
the goal of the laboratory was to create
knocks knocks one knock out in Ellis
5:13 cells using a new super CRISPR cos
9 single cell Western was used to guy
clonal selection of knockout cells in
addition to PCR and traditional Western
blood testing
first we used a single service turn to
detect the knocks one knock down level
in parental in empty vector cells and
also in pools of cells that contained
two p2 or p3 guided RNA we could observe
very low NOx one not very low percent of
Earth positive NOx one negative says
suggesting that clonal selection from
the pool population is further needed
about 100 clones were selected from both
the T 2 and T 3 clones and tested first
with PCR and traditional Western for NOx
one expression selected cones were
further evaluated with single cell
Reston
this slide shows the data from the cast
9 empty vector clone and I want to
mention that Knox one is known to be not
a neat not to be an easy protein to work
with it was detected with a custom-made
Mouse antibody and you can see from the
left hand side image that Knox wand runs
as a smear on single sebweston we used
earth as loading code or a loading
control to identify all the occupied
where's the 1d plot on the top right
hand shows the expression level of Earth
and NOx 1 while the enumeration table at
the bottom highlights that the
percentage of Earth 1 NOx one- says it's
eight point eight flow is eight point
eight percent in the empty vector
control cell line with this slide I
would like to mention the unusually high
percent of Earth negative cells that
have knocked one signal the enumerations
table shows that we could detect about
14% of says that the expression of 1 but
Knox 1 but not ugh
currently we don't know the biological
significance of this finding but it
might reflect - OTP diversity of cells
observed during cell culture this slide
shows the data from the best clone the T
- 10 you can see the nice dark image on
the left with no annex one signal you
can see the nice earth signal on the
right and even if in this case the
analysis was skewed toward the detection
of false positives because we wanted to
make sure that we detect all the NOx one
positive says we could detect only a few
cells that were Knox one positive about
3% and on the 1d plot you can see that
the Express
not knocks one in these few cells it's
very low we could also identify two
special clones in which there were many
cells and only one of them is shown here
in which many cells show no knocks one
expression but about 17% of them have a
relatively high Knox one expression as
shown on the 1d plot this silence showed
on traditional western blood showed
almost no detectable level of Knox one
or very low NOx one level but with
single serviced and we could identify
that this is a mixed cell population and
with further a corner selection probably
it would be very easy to get knocks one
knock dance and the last data slide the
I would like to present the quantitative
data from parental several empty vector
clones and also some of the selected
Knox Wan clones you can see on the
y-axis the normalized
Knox one level is shown on a logarithmic
scale and direct red line represents the
geometric mean the local group of cells
contain no Knox one only arc the middle
group of cells show expression of both
Knox one and oak and the top group of
the cells have Noxon expression but no
expression you can see that the best
clone the t2 tan clone stands out from
the rest by having almost no Knox one
expression in any of the cells and from
the graph you can see the distribution
of the different cells in these clones
but you don't have an idea about the
percentage the percent of knocks one
knock down cells is shown in the bar
graphs here on the bottom
almost all t2 tensors var knocks on Knox
one negative also the t3 services were
almost all Knoxville negative these data
correlates well with the reactive oxygen
species measurement that is a functional
readout for Knox one in these cells
finally I would like to summarize in the
slide the main findings from the two
single serviced and project we could
successfully detect more than 10 targets
including phosphoproteins and newly
synthesized transcription factors using
multiple cycles of staining and
stripping in a very characterized
cellular system we identified two states
of Cephas England caps as possibly
representing monomers and dimers and
heterogeneity in cells expressing the
low molecular weight the high molecular
rate or both forms we identify two
subsets of length of control cells cells
a base baseline and partially activated
cells we use single cell destined to
guide selection of knocks one knock out
clones after in usable CRISPR Cassadine
manipulation to complement PCR and
traditional Western blood screening
finally I would like to acknowledge all
the people who contributed to this
project I think with my 20 year long
boss Peter and Bloomberg who is now
happily retired special thanks to
members of our laboratory my great
colleague and head of the core Jessie
Chan our talented summer student Marion
Nvidia and our wonderful volunteers Rama
Sri Satya nori the world with Agnes who
has from the Duras of lab on the North
Lawn project we really appreciate the
discussions and the interaction with
Kelley Gardner Eddie Stobart
and Josh Majo who are the real experts
in single serviced and and Scout thanks
for all the support we got from Stephan
Swagger Brandi Oh Jackson
and cron and thank you for your
attention
Thank You dr. today and dr. Gardner for
your presentations a quick reminder for
our audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. kadai and dr. Gardner will answer as
many questions as time permits the first
question is stripping efficiency and how
many times can stripping be done what is
the protocol for stripping and repro
being the chips and how challenging is
it to implement
the stripping efficiency is generally
done done in harsh stripping buffered
that contains 2% SDS meketa Nora
degrees and based on our experience the
efficiency depends on the signal
that can be objectively measured and
calculated using scout
although we are very satisfied with the
stripping efficiency from the chips we
use the strategy to start with the most
important weak signal are when we
approved the chips and later check the
stronger and reference signals I was not
a big fan of stripping membranes when
doing traditional Vestas but we are
pretty pleased with a stripping result
of the on the chips thank you how easy
is out software to use CAD software is
used to quantitate signals for each
individual cell on the chip converting
images to numbers to enable quantitative
comparison correlations I have
experience with the version 2 of the
software that is easy to use especially
after learning how it works from the
online tutorial and spending some time
getting used with its logic the later
versions include more automation in
detecting specific signal versus the
dirt and one of these features is auto
exclusion which is a significant
improvement as it is very tedious to
manually inspect each signal for each
cell for several hundreds of cells the
software provides useful visualization
tools for data presentation and as you
could see from the the presentation
these are lane plots to see chip loading
and separation of proteins histogram 1
and 2d plots enumeration table +
quantitative data can be exported as CSV
and FCS files for users who want to use
their own method to present findings
additionally feedback about the software
and requests for improvement are
welcomed by the software development
team
thank you in the presented studies work
is used as a reference protein loading
control in multiple occasions in regular
Western blots generally actin vinculin
and gap th are used as loading controls
could you explain why videos are mostly
because of convenience it's a clean
signal it has a very nice noise signal
to noise ratio the lab has both Mouse
and rabbit antibodies it's a low
molecular weight signal that often does
not overlap with the other signal
additionally acting it's not efficiently
detected on single cell vessels and as
you get the age runs as a tetramer as
you could see from the presentation and
we didn't like to use it that much to
Bellini's was affected by 3m 'try p.m. a
treatment and the including could be
another option
plus the irk was probably the cheapest
antibody that we have
thank you in the introductory slides
assistant stated that the single-cell
Western uses Western antibodies could
you comment on if all antibodies work
and what about the phospho sucess if ik
antibodies based on the company's
experience about 70% of antibodies that
keep a good signal and traditional
Western blood work for single service
turn in our experience for the PKC
signaling studies similarly about 2/3 of
the antibodies were for single salvus
than we had a few that didn't so and a V
if we go into phosphor specific
antibodies for example the phosphor
serine 299 antibody worked was the
forceful but the first for tyrosine 3:11
didn't one explanation for lack of
signal and single service then could be
that the proteins are not fully
denatures because there is no reducing
agent present no heat it's a very short
life this time
so some epitopes might stay buried not
accessible to the antibody but in our
experience for the majority of the
signals that we wanted to detect after
trying several antibodies we could find
one that worked
thank you how many cells did you load
per chip
the optimal cell loading of a chip it's
about 1,000 cells under 6,400 Wells
because this one gets enough cells on
the chip to address heterogeneity but
possibly minimizes the number of tablets
for the control chips in this case about
500 600 cells were loaded while on the
pmh if we loaded about 1,400 cells the
standard protocol from the company for
single cell Western world flow is to
load one ml of 100,000 cells on a on a
chip this number can go can go can be
lowered as low as 10,000 cells per ml or
even lower because it's just you waiting
long enough and then you can load more
and more cells on the West basically the
cells enter in the well based on gravity
and the loading really depends on the
number of the cells and the time for
loading the chips recently even though
the recommendations from the company is
100 thousand cells per ml recently I
prefer to load 50 thousand or 40,000
cells per ml especially forces that tend
to aggregate
thank you it looks like you have
excellent repeatability and tight
correlations for the same antibody
probed on different probing cycles
suggesting minimal sample loss over
stripping and repro being cycles after
seventh cycle do you think the sample
was still stable enough that you could
have gone through additional stripping
and reap robing cycles to further
increase multiplexing I would later
showed excellent correlation in pkc data
signal between probing cycles nine and
twelve on the same chip this suggests to
us that the sample loss has been low
enough over the stripping and reproving
cycles that we are still getting
accurate measurements of pkc data
heterogeneity after twelve probing
cycles thank you why did you use so many
rounds of stripping and reap robing
versus utilizing more channels on your
four color scanner
in in my case the time was not that
important and I preferred to see every
single signal especially Wendy Wendy by
probing them for the first time as a
single signal this one included
additional probing and washing steps to
probe not to combine the antibodies but
to detect them separately but my
preference to was again add especially
at the beginning to use them one by one
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question how many signals can
be detected and is there a theoretical
maximum I don't think that there is a
theoretical maximum in in how many
signals can be detected the number of
detectable targets probably depends on
the antibody species for example if one
uses rabbit mouse read go to antibodies
it also depends on how good the
antibodies I it will depend on the
molecular weight of the signals and the
stripping efficiency I can see one
problem with several rounds of stripping
and repro beings as we get to really
high numbers because the chip gets
dirtier with multiple rounds of
manipulation lint and dust from the
environment gas on the chip or there are
you know every day with the chief
manipulation there are multiple multiple
scratches so maybe one factor that
limits the number of signals that can be
detected it's basically the chip
handling thank you
I would like
to once again thank doctor doctor today
and dr. Gardner for their presentations
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor proteins simple for
underwriting today's educational webcast
until next time goodbye